well a lot of you have asked for it and
i figure now is a pretty good time to
start because if I do say so myself me
and video games pretty good mix so this
weekend September third fourth and fifth
I'm gonna be at PAX in Seattle which is
pretty much like the e3 of the Northwest
you know games that aren't out yet and
all that cool [ __ ] pretty much worth
going to in my book and I figure I'll
just bring my camera and bring it to you
too I'm hoping to get a glimpse of and
hopefully play like donkey kong country
returns and mortal kombat star wars the
old republic and hopefully get my hands
on a 3ds let you know if that shit's
worth it now pax is huge and i'll try to
cover as much as possible and bring you
all the cool [ __ ] but to make sure i
bring you what you want to see comment
below and let me know what you want me
to show you what do you want to see it
packs and don't say my junk you'll
embarrass me and should if you're
actually lucky enough to go to pax and
you happen to see me there say hi i
always like to meet the people so
comment below and let me know what you
want me to show you a pax and i will try
to bring you some awesome tacular ism
this from pax actually that one might
not be a word i'm gonna call it and say
that's probably not a word that's not a
word but it's my word and in the spirit
of video games if anyone can tell me
what this is from props to you yep
that's real and yes i was flexing shut
up